herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen halle
deutschland woche und zu unserem corona
kompakt schön dass sie mit dabei sind
wir sprechen gleich mit einem
katastrophenforscher der prognosen
abgeben kann wie corona unsere
gesellschaft verändern wird außerdem
demos gottesdienste die wieder
stattfinden und die schule öffnungen
sind heute thema
im abstand von 20 sekunden verlassen die
schüler der aventinus schule im
bayerischen abensberg dem bus warten
geduldig bis der vorangegangene sich die
hände desinfiziert hat und tragen
außerhalb der klassenräume ihre masken
erster corona schultag mit absoluter
disziplin soll der unterricht hier
wieder möglich werden
dafür werden alle vorschriften sorgsam
beachtet die zum teil schon gewohnte
routine soll zusätzlich sicherheit geben
noch sieben wochen dann mit masken und
nach mit sicherheitsabstand und alles in
die klasse zu gehen aber ich würde sagen
es ist nicht so schlimm
also ich finde es ist jetzt nicht die
klassenkameradinnen und so zu sehen
und jetzt auch der unterricht lehrer zu
machen ist schon besser
in den letzten wochen hatten
lehrerschaft bund und länder um eine
möglichst schnelle lösung gerungen
schulleiter wolfgang brey ist froh dass
das leben zurück ist in den schul gängen
und dem familienfrieden in so manchem
haushalt dürfte es auch nicht schaden
ich glaube dass also unser berufsbild
jetzt auch durch die korona zeit
gestiegen ist weil viele eltern mich
jetzt letzte gebet nahm ja wir kennen
das hat mir seinen frommen die kinder
wie die schule kinder und die
schülerinnen und schüler glaube ich auch
für die oberstufe kehrt somit vielerorts
ein stück normalität ein
doch die partiellen lockerungen sorgen
auch für kritik zu ungleich zu unfair zu
wenig gerecht sein die neuen regelungen
beklagen die skeptiker
die anfängliche angst ist inzwischen
mancherorts wie hier im sächsischen
görlitz der skepsis gewichen zu lax
gingen bund und länder mit den
grundrechten der menschen um getroffen
um in zeiten der krise gemeinsam zu
singen
die gemeinschaft zu stärken und die in
also zu fragen was das eigentlich ist
mit den ganzen grundrechten die ja doch
sehr stark beschnitten sind ganz klar
mussten schutz für diejenigen da sein
die den brauchen aber es kann nicht
ganze leben ruiniert werden für viele
selbstständige kämen finanzielle
unterstützung und die gelockerten regeln
zu spät beklagen die demonstranten auch
das wirrwarr um die infizierten zahlen
am wochenende sorgte zusätzlich für
unmut die johns hopkins universität geht
derzeit von 165 1745 infizierten 6866
toten und 132 1700 genesenen aus und
zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt professor
doktor martin voss er ist
sozialwissenschaftler und
katastrophenforscher und beschäftigt
sich mit der bewältigung und der
prävention von krisen herr voss ab heute
treten die ersten lockerungen in kraft
was könnte da im besten und im
schlimmsten fall auf uns zukommen
ich wünsche dir dass ich in der lage
wäre gesellschaftliche prozesse zu
prognostizieren das kann ich leider
nicht ich kann nur ein bisschen
beobachten und sortieren und gucken was
tut sich da gerade wenn sie das so
fragen und besten im schlechtesten fall
am besten wenn wir sehen dass die
lockerungen sich nicht negativ auf die
infizierten zahlen auswirken dass die
selbst so sensitiv sind dass sie die
maßnahmen umsetzen in dem raum ihres
möglichkeit des möglichen
jeder hat natürlich so unterschiedliche
handhabung weisen wie man mit bestimmten
situationen umgeht und da ist auch jeder
einzelne gefragt das entsprechend auch
in den alltag zu integrieren
also wenn das alles gut gelaufen
vielleicht noch ein bisschen
fortuna dazugekommen im sinne von
klimaeffekt also sagen höher die
temperaturen dämpft das vielleicht auch
ein bisschen die zusätzlichen
erkrankungen
wenn wir dann auch sagen die die die
maßnahmen werden wirklich
sozialverträglich umgesetzt so dass das
auch weiterhin die leute bereit sind
sich daran zu halten dann könnt ihr das
alles natürlich einen guten weg nehmen
die der schlechte falle wäre der dass
das alles umgekehrt nicht passiert dass
wir sehen die erkrankungszahlen gehen
wieder hoch und das braucht doch noch
mal einen lock down der dann
gravierender wirken würde wie ich denke
weil viele einfach nicht mehr können
bleibt abzuwarten danke professor fonds
und gleich werden sie uns netterweise
noch weitere fragen beantworten
eine lockerung auf die viele schon
sehnsüchtig gewartet haben ist die dass
die friseursalons wieder aufmachen ich
gehöre zu den glücklichen die auch in
dieser woche einen termin bekommen haben
aber der ansturm auf die haarsalon es
ist groß und deswegen braucht man
erstmal viel geduld und einiges läuft
auch jetzt anders der salon bis
pfingsten ausgebucht glücklich alle die
in dieser woche noch einen termin
bekommen haben bereits für erste die die
konferenz ungewohnt für ihm trocken
haarschnitt gibt's nicht mehr an die
wäsche vorab muss er sich gewöhnen
so sollen ihren vom kopf die sich
eventuell noch in den haaren befinden
als klar war dass heute aufgemacht wird
habe ich sofort versucht wird den ersten
termin zu sichern weil wenn ich einzig
jahren kann sie das lange haare masken
pflicht klar für friseur und kunden dass
wir jetzt alle dass gegenseitiger
solidarität mit den ganzen schnitt haben
wenn man sich das jetzt anguckt dann ist
das nicht besonders viel hygienischer
als wenn wir ohne maske arbeiten würden
ich darf ja gar nichts im gesicht machen
das heißt ich darf das gesicht überhaupt
nicht sauber
und weil gesichtslos arbeiten verboten
ist geht auch keine bad oder wimpern
pflege
augenbrauen bruder und damit kann sie
sich jetzt ein bisschen über wasser
halten nach der zwangspause druck der
laden wieder aber dafür müssen alle die
strengen hygiene auflagen einhalten
heike und bürger kenzler haben zuvor in
ihrem salon für den notwendigen schutz
gesorgt und wegen des erforderlichen
mindestabstands auch arbeitsplätze
abgebaut
das heißt sie haben keine chance den
umsatz aufzuholen weil sie gar nicht die
kunden in der frequenz bearbeiten dürfen
und können auch körperlich nicht können
wie sie müssten um diese sechs wochen
aufzuholen
ohne preiserhöhung wird es nicht gehen
die hier gene auflagen fordern mehr zeit
pro kunde desinfektionsmittel masken
handschuhe kosten geld färben zum
beispiel ist komplizierter und die maske
stört schon die kunden muss es gerade
jetzt so halte ich es mache weisels kann
ich weder um den bogen noch im nacken
irgendwas arbeiten ich hatte dahinter
mit meinem fühlen wenn ich nachher mit
dem fürsten arbeite es ist sehr sehr
schwierig beratung ist nur über den
spiegel erlaubt plexiglas masken
erleichtern die kommunikation etwas für
mich ist wichtig auch dass die kunden
und meine mimik sid ich auch die mimik
sehe das ist für mich am schwierigsten
mit diesen masken ich kann nicht sehen
wie es die kunden darauf wenn sie so
eine maske hat sie fröhlich ist sie
traurig außerdem will man ja auch ein
wenig raten beim friseur lesen ist nicht
mehr könnten ihr viren auf den
illustrierten sitzen bonbons sind noch
erlaubt eine tasse kaffee oder ein glas
wasser aber tabu heike keßler hat jetzt
anderes für ihre kunden den kühlschrank
natürlich für unsere mädels auch mit dem
pinken strohhalm das muss ja alles ein
bisschen aufeinander abgestimmt seien
keine offenen getränke mehr
wir haben jetzt müssen wir haben jetzt
stilles wasser wir haben nämlich die
apfelschorle und solange die sonne
scheint gibt es hier im salon auch noch
die neue variante freiluft schnitt
verbraucht schon einen spiegel
ja einer der mehr als 160000 mit dem
corona virus infizierten ist kathrin
spindler
sie hatte sich ziemlich früh mit corona
angesteckt und zwar bei einem skiurlaub
in ischgl
aber nachdem sie das überstanden hat
folgt schon der nächste corona schock
das virus bedroht ihre gesamte existenz
verdammt zur zwangspause
gastronomen katrin spindler aus dem
thüringer hohen feldern weiß nicht wie
es weitergeht corona erschüttert ihr
leben doppelt erst infiziert sie sich
mit dem virus jetzt der korona shutdown
im gastgewerbe wenn man jetzt eine
krankheit hat zum beispiel da weiß man
das geht irgendwann vorbei im moment
steht man da und weiß nicht wann es
vorbei ist also man kann sich nicht auf
den tags vorbereiten und steht in der
luft sozusagen ihr problem ihre
gaststätte steht auf einem campingplatz
und der muss geschlossen bleiben
für sie nicht mal außer haus verkauf
möglich seit vier jahren baut sie mit
ihrem mann rené die gastronomie hier
immer wieder aus eigentlich wollte es
jetzt eine minigolfanlage eröffnen
doch nun droht der lebenstraum zu
platzen ich komme vielleicht auch noch
so ein zwei wochen hin mit biegen und
brechen aber dann eben nicht mehr
dann war es das die spindlers wohnen
auch auf dem campingplatz
der bungalow ihr eigenheim noch bevor
corona ihr berufsleben fast ruiniert hat
war kathrin spinnler selbst betroffen
urlaub nur in der wintersaison doch
genau das wird der gastronomen zum
verhängnis ausgerechnet dieses jahr
fällt sie mit ihren freundinnen ins
winterparadies ist ungefährt auf dem
berg und denkt an nichts
wie auch
erst piste dann party ausgelassene
stimmung beim apres-ski corona scheint
offiziell weit weg noch doch dann
beginnt der albtraum ist wird zum krone
hotspot immer mehr menschen infizieren
sich trotzdem bleiben die pisten
geöffnet die hütten abends proppenvoll
[Applaus]
katrin beschleicht ein mulmiges gefühl
ich konnte die ganze nacht nicht
schlafen für mich war nur das eine thema
wie geht es hier weiter wir haben auf
dem zimmer gesessen haben im market gibt
es neue nachrichten gibt es irgendwas
neues gibt es irgendwelche vorkehrungen
muss man irgendwas beachten nichts
dergleichen wurde wurde gesagt oder auch
im hotel konnte man auch niemanden
ansprechen die wussten auch nichts und
ja und nach der nacht dienstag nacht
schlaflos so ziemlich war für mich früh
klar ich werde hier nicht bleiben
katrin bricht den urlaub ab in der
hoffnung sich noch nicht angesteckt zu
haben vorsichtshalber besteht sie auf
einen test ich wollte definitiv auch
nicht diejenige sein die aus dem urlaub
kommt nach deutschland kommt ohne
symptome hier frei rumläuft und dann
wahrscheinlich noch ganz viele andere
leute ansteckt vermutlich hat sie damit
vielen anderen die erkrankungen erspart
denn ihr ergebnis ist positiv in diesem
moment an mit dem anruf sagt alles
runter und man denkt oh nein
was passiert jetzt mit mir gefangen in
den eigenen vier wänden es folgen 14
tage quarantäne
kathrins mutter bringt die einkäufe sie
steigt aus und ich kann sie sehen aber
ich kann nichts tun ich kann wieder
hallo sagen ich kann sie nicht umarmen
nicht die tür aufmachen winken durch die
scheibe
das war ich kam mir vor wie eine
verbrecherin seine frau im haus rené im
campingwagen und obwohl die frau
luftlinie zehn meter weiter weg ist
fühlt man sich dann auch schon allein
und sehr eingeengt dass die behörden im
österreichischen ischgl nicht er
eingeschritten sind macht kathrin noch
immer sauer
deshalb hat sie sich einer sammelklage
angeschlossen und das ist schön wie eng
man sich da tummelt
immerhin sie übersteht ihre krone
erkrankung ohne gravierende symptome
rené und katrin stürzen sich in die
arbeit sie wollen bereit sein wenn es
wieder losgeht
aber was passiert wenn die gaststätte
noch für monate geschlossen bleibt das
würde ich mir gar nicht ausmalen wollen
ja weil ich glaube schon dass wir das
nicht überleben
aber aufgeben wollen sie auf keinen fall
um den umsatz zu steigern haben sie
jetzt mit ihren letzten reserven eine
softeismaschine angeschafft die soll
zusätzlich kunden anlocken
sie hoffen dass corona ihnen zumindest
eine gute seite zeigt und viele urlauber
dieses jahr in deutschland bleiben
der katastrophenforscher professor dr
martin fonds ist die uns jetzt aus
berlin zugeschaltet herr fonds hätten
wir ihrer meinung nach besser auf die
krise vorbereitet sein müssen hinterher
immer ein bisschen schlauer
ich glaube wir haben uns doch über die
letzten jahrzehnte zu sehr eingeengt
dass wir es mit hochwasser zu tun haben
mit starken wind das ist sozusagen der
katastrophen typus den wir aus der
vergangenheit kennen und darauf haben
wir unsere vorbereitung ausgerichtet
wir haben uns das zu bequem gemacht wir
haben nicht wirklich uns dafür geöffnet
dass es im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
ganz andere szenarien gibt in einer
vernetzten dynamischen welt hängt alles
aufs engste miteinander zusammen und
dann sind die effekte von leichten
impulsen wie ein virus der irgendwo in
china ist ein weg um die welt antritt am
ende wirklich zerstörerische mir gerade
den berichten auch gesehen und gehört
wie vielfältig dann die auswirkungen
sind und noch vielfältiger vielleicht in
der zukunft auch nicht zeigen werden
alles das haben wir nicht wirklich so
gedacht also da sind wir zu eng gewesen
mit unseren blick und ich denke wir
hoffen jedenfalls dass wir daraus lernen
dass wir in der zukunft und da breiter
aufstellen mit viel forschung die wir
heute so gar nicht haben wir haben eben
locker keinen zugang zu diesen gefahren
natürlich auch mit antworten die dann
ganz anders geartet werden
ein schutzdamm gegen dem wir uns links
hochwasser abbilden können sondern im
mit einem blick darauf wie sind
eigentlich familien betroffen die mit
vielen kindern in einer zu engen wohnung
leben müssen und der pandemie
bedingungen dieser art komplexität die
müssen wir zukünftig uns wirklich
genauer anschauen und dann haben uns
vorbereitet systemrelevante berufe wie
krankenschwestern altenpfleger oder
kassierer die haben wenig einkommen und
halten ihr den laden so am laufen was
meinen sie werden wertschätzungen und
vielleicht auch lohn künftig steigen
ja der kollege aminati von der münchner
universität hat gerade gesagt dass sich
die gesellschaft nicht so grundlegend
ändern wird ich bin dadurch andere
meinungen nicht so sehr im strukturellen
auf den ersten blick wenn wir das nicht
so leicht erkennen aber hintergrund
passiert auch ganz viel
ich glaube die ihre frage trifft da
schon den punkt wir werden anders über
solche berufe nachdenken und dahinter
steckt doch grundsätzliches wollen wir
eigentlich berufe tätigkeiten danach
belohnen wo angebot und nachfrage eben
den werten schieben oder müssen nicht
doch darüber nachdenken ob wir solche
positionen nach ihrer
gemeinwohlorientierung ausrichten und
bezahlen also welchen beitrag leisten
sie dann für andere
das ist natürlich ein anderer ansatz das
ist eine grundsatzfrage die wir nicht
sofort ganz radikal anders beantworten
werden als in der vergangenheit aber ich
glaube es tut sich an so vielen
gesellschaftlichen lebensbereichen doch
so viel dass wir am ende in einer
anderen gesellschaft landen werden
können sie dann noch ein beispiel geben
was das noch sein könnte na ja
grundsätzlich ist im grunde jeder glaube
ich für sich mit seiner realität ganz
anders konfrontiert wie erleben uns
individuell in unseren vier wänden in so
enger sozialbeziehungen vielleicht mit
der familie oder aber auch gerade auf
der großen distanz zu den uns vertrauten
wir verändern damit unsere wahrnehmung
unserer sensitivität für einander zum
guten und auch zum schlechten also wir
lernen natürlich was uns fehlt wir
lernen vielleicht auch bestimmte
situationen einzuschätzen aber rüttelt
an uns allen und das überträgt sich in
alle bereiche bis hin zur frage gehen
wir eigentlich zukünftig solidarischer
doch mit anderen kulturen gesellschaften
weltweit um sehen dass das alles doch
direkte auswirkungen hat wie wir eben in
friedenszeiten miteinander umgehen das
kommt dann am ende in der krise auch auf
sonst auf und zurück also es tut sich im
unterbau der gesellschaft wahnsinnig
viel wünschenswert danke professor
martin faust nach berlin und unser
corona kompakt das finden sie auch auf
youtube auf dem kanal der heute.de